welcome back to the stronger by science
fireside chat series I'm your host Greg
knuckles joined today by my temporary
guest host eric drexler yeah thanks for
having me on and everyone that's
listening that continues to email and
message Greg begging for you to come
back go ahead and keep up the good work
it seems like he's really breaking down
and giving in which is fantastic don't
do that ok let's get right into it with
this episode so these are you know
entirely us answering your questions are
talking about subjects you would like us
to talk about and something that a few
people asked about clearly indicates
that you [ __ ] don't know us at
all
several people wanted to know what's in
our wardrobe
what threads are we rocking these days
what you know when we go out on the
street how do we turn heads it's a trick
so what are what are you rocking these
days yeah you know I have to admit I
know that it's vain but I am a big-time
brand guy you know it's I've got my
clothing brands and I like to stay on
brand with them so I view it kind of
like luxury cars you know what I mean
you want to get the whole lineup that
the SUV the sports car all from the same
from the same lineup and for me I'm a
big time George guy and I know you are
too but I'm gonna steal your thunder
here a little bit so a lot of people
probably know George is the store brand
for the I guess you'd say
upscale Walmart clothing so if you're
getting your jeans your dress pants your
dress shirts your ties your belts your
workout gear I'm pretty much George
head-to-toe there are some some money
only because you can't access vets or
Grey's anymore right that's now you have
to explain the concept of FETs or Grey's
yes so the the gym at UNC is is called
Fetzer gymnasium and if you didn't want
to bring your own workout clothes if
you're going for a workout or going to
play basketball you could rent what
everyone lovingly referred to as Fetzer
Grey's which were
t-shirts and like cotton gym shorts that
I believe UNC purchased in approximately
1978 and that was that's what that's
what you wore all the time and I'm gonna
telling you right now until pretty
recently Trek stand own socks he just
liked her he just checked out Fetzer
gray socks and that's all he wore okay
well first of all I made good on all
that all the Fetzer graze all the socks
were returned to their rightful place
maybe a time or two I would get a pair
of socks behind you know and I'd say oh
there's an extra pair of socks here I'll
wear those today but I made good so
you're not telling on anything you know
I'm a upstanding citizen and all that
stuff got it's just the concept of a
functioning adult not owning socks
I owned some but you know the Fetzer
grades were really comfortable they were
nice and they had the they had the the
t-shirts were all like extra large but
really they fit like a double XL oh yeah
and yeah I just felt like I was straight
out of like a mid-90s bodybuilding
training video I'm not gonna lie those
shirts were comfortable as hell they
were and it was it was like back in the
day where everybody just wore those
enormous t-shirts that just kind of hung
off your body and man they were great
so yeah the Fetzer grades were a huge
part of the rotation along with the
George brand from head to toe now there
are some deviations from that things
that are given to me I will wear
uncritically what whatever article of
clothing is given to me I will wear and
I'll hang on to him for a while so my
current winter coat you've seen the the
red one that I wear often that was
actually purchased for my brother when
he was I think in ninth grade so that
would have put me right around the age
of twelve when that was purchased and
what is that sixteen years later it's
still going strong it's a high-quality
high-quality coat and I'm never gonna
let it go ever so I I do hand-me-downs
big-time I do the George brand Fetzer
Gray's are out of the rotation
unfortunately
um now a lot of Christmas and birthday
gifts going back to as long as I can
remember luckily you know my mother she
knows that I would not have clothing
unless it was actually forced upon me
and given to me she also is really good
at picking out clothes so I think every
single time I've ever been told like hey
you look nice today I was wearing
something that my mother purchased for
me so she's always right on the money
with those with those purchases but the
problem there is I have a new policy
I hate accumulating things like material
objects of any kind I consider them to
be clutter they drive me nuts
and so the new policy is no more buying
clothing for me and so basically my
clothing line up is set now that that
door is shut I have all the clothing I'm
never going to have and yeah so that's
the clothing side another thing people
some people know this about me big-time
sneaker head so last year I believe it
was payless shoes had a liquidation sale
I think that was the name of the of the
the brand that that went out of business
but basically everything in the store
had to go I showed up I got as many
shoes as a person could possibly carry
out of a store I don't think I'm ever
gonna wear shoes again or purchase new
shoes again and yeah I mean I got
everything that would kind of fit around
my size foot I purchased and I got out
of there so based on that summary you're
probably wondering Eric you know being
this in tune with style how has that
worked out for you over the years and I
have actually been the subject of not
one but two fashion interventions when I
first got to grad school my colleagues
wonderful colleagues they tried to in a
very subtle way be like hey Eric you
should probably dress more like a person
would and maybe a little bit more
professionally and I just didn't get the
subtle hints and so eventually they had
to be like dude wait what's happening
you know wear some clothing that a
person would would typically wear out in
public so that was the first
intervention I'm not sure if it really
stuck
I tried but I kind of fell back into old
habits and then a guy that I coach
powerlifting with he was like 65 70 at
the time he pulled me aside I was asking
him a bunch of Statistics questions
because he was a statistician by trade
and he was like after this very
long-winded question he just pulled me
aside he's like dude forget about the
stats no one cares what the hell are you
wearing you need to start wearing like
and so I think once someone above the
age of 65 kind of pulls you aside and
says what the hell is going on where is
your fashion sense I think that's when
you know you you actually do kind of
have a problem there but but anyway
that's kind of my approach to clothing
it's work so far I'm really happy with
how I look every day and I don't get
positive comments but surely I will
eventually I would think and my advice
to people my final parting piece of
advice here when it comes to clothing
collect as many t-shirts as you possibly
can from random events from random
companies random sport teams that you
participated on you can never have too
many of those t-shirts sometimes you cut
the sleeves off but that is the final
staple in my wardrobe and that is pretty
much my approach to style now Greg I
know fashion is important to you as well
so why don't you tell us what you do for
style yeah so I own nine shirts exactly
nine that I bought at Walmart for
between three and five dollars apiece
about three or four years ago and that's
all I wear
yeah now blue is a big fixture in that
lineup yeah I mean so red is my favorite
color when I was younger I had a lot of
of red t-shirts Walmart doesn't make
that many red t-shirts
unfortunately so a lot of Blues a lot of
gray is a lot of greens and buy a lot of
each I mean like I have approximately
two shirts of each of those colors and
yeah that's that's all I wear on my
upper body and then I have three pairs
of identical black athletic shorts that
I cycle through they are all at least
five years old
I had one and only one jacket that I
wore every day in the winter for about
five years it recently started like the
pocket started tearing off of it it
started getting holes in it has a lot of
stains etc so I found another identical
version of the same jacket and now I
wear that all the time when I went to
grad school I didn't want to have to
think about what I wore so I went to you
guessed it Walmart and bought five
identical UNC shirts and two identical
pairs of slacks just so I could put on
essentially my uniform every day and
yeah that's a that's my style
uh so one one big upgrade I did make
recently is I used to only wear like
those ten to twelve dollar Walmart
slip-on shoes I've recently upgraded to
a pair of $25.00 Skechers they were on
sale they're very comfortable they seem
like they're gonna be more durable than
the Walmart shoes I am a little
concerned that I may be experiencing
lifestyle creep so just you know his
business is going pretty well making
more money I'm afraid that this increase
in my shoe budget may just completely
ruin our household finances as a percent
increase it is a pretty pretty dramatic
change oh yeah I mean I started recently
spending a hundred and fifty percent
more on shoes so that's yeah you know
that that's something to keep in mind
but ya know I I consistently look like
trash and unlike you who who has had two
interventions I've had dozens of
attempted interventions and they just
don't go anywhere because I'm very much
like a comfort above all type person
it's like all of my shirts are two sizes
too big my athletic shorts are baggy and
long I just feel good you know
yeah and so yeah I mean I never leave
the house
anyways so like who cares now there was
a moment when we were we were at an
event in Coastal Carolina that we were
both speaking at it was like it was an
event this was an event for the ISSN a
good friend of mine Jason Khalifa was
running it he's been on the podcast and
Greg and I were both supposed to speak
and Greg was speaking last and I
remember it was like 45 minutes before
Greg's talk and he's wearing the gym
shorts and the t-shirt and then it's
like 30 minutes before the talk and he's
wearing the gym shorts and the t-shirt
and I was like you know I know this
isn't like the fanciest event of all
time but you are speaking at an academic
event and I was very concerned that you
were actually gonna go speak and then
finally right at the last minute you
ended up stepping out of the room and
changing and I got to breathe that sigh
of relief because I was like I think
he's gonna go for it this is a
consistent theme just with our our
friendship you think that I am a much
worse and and much more socially unaware
person than I actually am like so true
like so dear listener whenever we hang
out with like some of Eric's friends or
like when he was when he was dating
before if he brought a new girl over he
would he would like stress the
importance to me of like not coming
across as a complete piece of [ __ ] like
not making a bunch of off-color jokes
and it's just like dude tricks you've
known me for years at this point we've
gone through many of these situations
together I haven't done that like that's
not what I do
like I I am not the same person with
like people I don't know or like in a
formal situation as I am when it's just
like two dudes hanging out but like I
think you think that I'm a complete
piece of [ __ ] honestly no that's not
true
but there have been times where I've
brought you specific top
that are off limits with I've been what
I've brought somebody over like you're
not allowed to talk about these things
so there is some truth to that but no
you know me my personality is I like to
plan for everything and so I'll say I
trust that Greg isn't going to say this
but what would be better than trusting
would be to officially make a statement
about it let's set some policy in place
for dinner this evening
yeah yeah but like you don't say that to
Lindsay no well Lindsay Lindsay is a
much better person than you in virtually
always I mean you're not wrong but it's
I don't think that there's like a
magnitude of difference in like
interpersonal awareness between the two
of us no I so the problem is I get to
hang out with you in more private right
that is in circumstances so I know what
you're capable of saying when that makes
me a little bit nervous sometimes yeah
but I never say that stuff I know but
it's it's like one of those things where
there could just be one erroneous like
the message just gets through your brain
filter and then then it's a catastrophe
so it's oh I just I like to make sure
that we are transparent about what's
off-limits at that particular engagement
fair enough
now one thing I want to stress before we
move on I mean going back to the ISSN
conference yeah go ahead
it would have been fine it was advice so
the thing about that conference is like
I don't know seems like maybe 80% of the
attendees probably more were students
who were just going for I don't know
what extra credit like taking a class
where they had to go to events or
whatnot
I don't know but there were a lot of
butts in the seats and a lot of very
young faces in the crowd early in the
day and I think that by the end of the
day they had been - enough to get the
credit they needed to get it was so this
is not an exaggeration I had the last
talk of the day theoretically the
keynote I mean I'm not one for labels
but I'm gonna call it a keynote I got up
to speak and most of the speakers were
gone Jason was still there you were
still there like some some of the other
speakers and organizers were there but
in terms of attendees who weren't like
formal formally associated with the
event there were three attendees left in
the idea specific number it was three
yeah boy there were eight people total
and five were either like Jason other
organizers other speakers yeah there
were three attendees no fault of Jason's
by the way I love Jason oh no no
absolutely not but yeah I could I could
have got up there naked like it would
have been it would have had the exact
same effect on a comparable number of
people it's probably true okay no before
we move on from clothing like I was
saying I want to stress one thing now we
are often very sarcastic on the podcast
my concern is that someone's gonna think
that we're being some elitist classist
[ __ ] with this I cannot stress
enough that this is exactly how both of
us dress we're not like joking around if
like oh yeah I get my clothes at Walmart
we get our clothes at Walmart
exclusively and I want to make sure
people don't think we're like you know
being smart asses about it yeah I know
um I used to get more clothes at yard
sales I don't have as much time for yard
saleing anymore yeah also I used to get
so the thing about my current wardrobe
is like I said I have exactly nine
shirts I bought at Walmart and they've
just held up really well like they've
made it a long time were I to Reese like
restock my t-shirt collection yard sales
would be on the table goodwill would be
on the table the top price that I would
ever be willing to spend for a t-shirt I
don't know seven bucks maybe actually
you know my girlfriend did recommend a
topic that actually fits in perfectly
here the question was aside from shoes
what do you think is the most expensive
item of clothing you've ever bought like
a dollar amount hmm
so I have owned some more expensive
items of clothing mostly some that like
my parents bought for me when I was
still in high school it's like I have
some bow ties that were reasonably
expensive oh wow I would not have
guessed that Oh like when I dress up I
wear a bow tie that that's my thing and
I have like a what's it called in Under
Armour hoodie for Harding University
where I did my undergrad that was pretty
pricey but in terms of things I've
purchased myself okay okay so this is
kind of cheating but I did get a
specific a specific bow tie for my
wedding mm-hmm but like that that's
that's a wedding garment yeah it's not
account it's not the same I bought a
pair of shoes I was like 40 bucks maybe
but you said no shoes yeah man I'm
flailing around I mean it couldn't be
more than $30 right it's probably not
more than 20 yeah I wouldn't think so so
I had some some sport coats mm that I
got a goodwill and sport coats at
Goodwill are still 18 bucks nice so I I
had like three $18 for coats and I think
I think that is the most expensive non
shoe article of clothing I've ever
bought you know my parting comment is
that I actually think you need an
intervention more than I did
oh I'm sure I do but I so I have enough
like decent articles of clothing from my
youth that when I go out in public I can
still look presentable it's just like
you know for kicking around the house I
just want to be comfortable I hear you
man all right so what's the most
expensive article of clothing you've
ever bought hmm I did finally within the
last couple years I got a nice winter
coat that's not like a ski kind of coat
if I go skiing I'm wearing the one from
whoa you've seen it no no so I
completely whiffed on something mm-hmm I
did get a nice coat and some thermal
pants for Iceland yeah oh yeah that's
that's important but yeah I got I got
nice coat I got it at Old Navy on a
Black Friday sale I think it was fifty
dollars and I think that anchors the
high end of my my clothing scale for
sure but my average price per garment
could it be more than $11 I just don't
see how it be possible mm-hmm but but
yeah so that that's clothing advice from
us and much like our relationship advice
probably wouldn't utilize it well so so
here's one thing I'll say and and I
think that I think that I'm probably
fortunate in that I can do this but part
of how I present how I present myself in
day-to-day life is intentional because
like if there is something that does
really grind my gears it's people who
are just like super elitist and like
yeah so III want to see how people will
treat me when they meet me if they you
know if they're going to make negative
assumptions about me based on how I look
yeah if I'm presenting myself how I
typically do and someone's still pretty
cool and I'm like okay you've passed the
first test we could potentially be
friends but yeah that's so the it is
partly strategic um I do know how to
dress well and present myself well and I
do have some nicer stuff in my closet
that I just literally never wear B I
mean I I want to see how people will
treat me if I don't put in the effort to
present myself well yeah you don't want
people to treat you differently or take
you more seriously just because you're
like super buttoned up and dressed super
well basically correct yeah yeah I mean
that makes sense for me I just have no
interest in clothing whatsoever like I'm
not doing it intentionally I'm just like
well I could get a shirt for thirty one
dollars or for eight I'm gonna get the
eight yeah yeah almost all if that makes
sense
all right so yeah like I said that that
is stronger by science clothing advice
not sure if I would necessarily take
much of it but
there it exists and now you've heard it
that is true um now someone asked us
about defining moments of our lives and
that that's a very interesting prompt to
talk about because I know for me there's
one very specific that I have in mind
and it's quite an interesting story that
really is relevant to like what I do was
stronger by science
so I remember very specifically one day
I know I've told this story on some
podcast but I don't think it's ours you
know you and I both talking to
microphones
countless hours per month like I don't
know where it went but it's somewhere
out there yeah yeah but um I was walking
home from the gym and I was in full
dreamer bulk mode you know we've talked
about that on the podcast I weighed 20
pounds more than I had any business
weighing at the time but I was fully
balked up and just like a rock just did
big mass and I was walking home from the
gym thinking about how my workout went
and kind of just walked right in front
of a car like I thought that it was a
one-way street but it was actually a
two-way street and so that that's a big
mistake
you want to make sure you know where
cars are coming from on the street you
only looked in half as many directions
as you should have correct yeah so so I
basically walked in front of this car
that was driving there was no traffic so
like it got me pretty good it's not like
it was like in stop-and-go traffic or
anything so anyway I get nailed by this
car totally my fault
but somehow you know kind of walk away
from a totally unscathed like I don't I
don't really get it but the angle was
right something about it was right and
the only thing that really hurt was I
landed with my hand outstretched and I
kind of bruised my palm so like I was
lifting the next day I just had to be
careful about where the bar went you
know what I mean and at that time I was
in that cycle that I've tried to talk
young body builders out of and the same
applies to power lifters - I would think
but a lot of times as a young
bodybuilder you want to do your first
show but you're like you know what I
don't think my arms are big enough and
so you take six eight weeks you focus on
your arms they're bigger now and you go
okay my arms are better but now that I
think about it my legs are kind of small
and then
focus on your legs for a couple months
you say before I go on stage I better
improve my chest a little bit you know
there's always something that you want
to fix before you get on stage you know
cuz you feel like your physique is 25
years in the making it's not just like
hey here's what I did this past year
yeah so I was in that cycle of thinking
about competing and never pulling the
trigger and just doing it I got hit by
the car and somehow I didn't get hurt
essentially at all and at that point I
realized I need to do a bodybuilding
show now otherwise I'm gonna get sick
or I'm gonna get hurt or I'm gonna walk
in front of another car like I'm gonna
do something stupid that's gonna prevent
me from being able to actually do a prep
and compete for the first time in your
life it gave you a sense of your own
mortality I guess so yeah or at least
like hey I'm pretty lucky that I'm
healthy enough to actually train right
now so I didn't feel like I could just
delay this forever yeah so I did a
bodybuilding show loved it was
absolutely fascinated by the process
bodybuilding got me into powerlifting my
interest in both of those things got me
into really evaluating the evidence
behind the fitness information I was
consuming at that time I was an exercise
science major and I intended to become a
physical therapist but the interest in
the evidence-based side of things and
the research underlying the the
recommendations I had seen in so many
different places that got me interested
in actually doing research within the
field of exercise science and sport
nutrition so getting hit by that car
which again was just kind of a random
occurrence got me into bodybuilding got
me into powerlifting got me into
research caused me to shift my my
graduate school plans and ultimately
shift my entire career trajectory so you
know honest to god I don't know if I
didn't get hit by that car that day I
really don't know if I would be working
in this field I think most likely I
would be working as a physical therapist
which is of course a fantastic
profession but it would have been a very
different trajectory for me I think so
whenever someone asked me of a big
pivotal defining moment in my life that
is the only one that really sticks out
as totally different from the rest no I
mean that that
a good vignette and I also think it's
it's good advice for people listening
like you know if you're casting about
you don't really know for sure what you
want to do with your life just like
walking traffic for a little bit it's
it's really good for for giving you that
sense of clarity I thought you're gonna
be serious I yeah you snuck up on me
there I thought you're gonna actually
give good advice but but no I I would
imagine there are probably some power
lifters out there who are thinking I'd
kind of like to compete to see what it's
all about but I don't want to compete
until I have a insert total number or
until I'm benching blank you know what I
mean wanting to hit a threshold before
you get into it and I think in some
cases it makes sense to say let's go
ahead and dive in and see what we can do
yeah yeah that doesn't mean everyone
should compete immediately but there are
instances where you've kicked that can
down the road a little bit too long and
it's it's time to dive in you know what
about you do you have any major defining
moments so kind of not quite as dramatic
as getting hit by a car but I also had
something that on its face was not such
a good thing happened to me that that
ended up putting me on the path I'm
currently on which which thus far seems
to be a pretty good path so I was big
into sports growing up played football
basketball baseball soccer played the
last three going into high school after
freshman year of high school I was
already into lifting but lifting
primarily for for football and
basketball more so basketball than
football went to football camp that
summer and it was kind of like the
reverse of your case because I was the
metaphorical car in this situation but
so I was I was a defensive lineman and
tight end slash slot receiver and we
were doing pursuit drills and I was the
only I was I was the only person on the
defensive line who was also a skilled
player on
offense and so I was the designated ball
carrier to like help all of these other
defensive lineman learn about pursuit
angles and I was I was a sophomore who
who was probably going to play on
varsity that upcoming year so it was all
of the varsity defensive lineman and we
had some big old boys on the team and
most of them just took like dog [ __ ]
pursuit angles so I didn't take that
much physical abuse either like make it
look like I'm gonna cut inside and just
beat him up the sideline or cut back in
and it was all fine but then this one
guy who his nickname was meat and that
will give you some idea of what his
physical complexion was meat
unfortunately took a very good pursuit
angle and so I had really no choice but
to try to run him over and so keep in
mind at this moment in my life I'm
probably like 155 160 like I was on the
defensive line through sheer grit and
meanness like I didn't belong there I
was I was a much more like prototypical
slot receiver so so meat had about a
hundred and twenty pounds on me I was
like well whatever like gotta do what I
gotta do so like I learned my head this
is before we knew that concussions were
a thing that happened and and were bad
so I just lowered my head and put it
right in meets face mask and ran him
straight over I was like oh he didn't
wrapped me up this is going fine and
that was like my last thought and then I
woke up in a puddle of my own vomit so I
gave myself a pretty bad concussion and
it actually turned out to be a really
really bad concussion I had to go to the
hospital the the person who like took
the x-ray basically said that if I had
another concussion of a similar
magnitude like I could potentially like
wind up in a vegetative state or have
very severe brain damage and so
you know they said hey don't do sports
with a contact element for a while so
that obviously knocked me out of
football season and they said at least
six months so that would have taken
through like week four of basketball
season so I couldn't try out for
basketball either those were those were
my two main sports I was pretty tore up
about that and it just so happened that
the guy who was coaching me for power or
for uh just like strength training to
get better at basketball and football
was Travis mash who now nowadays most
people know him as a weightlifting coach
but he was doing all powerlifting back
then he was an incredibly good power
lifter in his own right he basically
said like hey there's this sport called
powerlifting where I think you'd be
pretty good at it
like you seem better at lifting weights
than actual real sports anyways and if
you experience head trauma it's because
you did something very very wrong it's
you know ideally not a sport that you
experience head trauma doing and so that
got me into powerlifting and that's
that's really what put me down the road
that I'm currently on so another like
very unfortunate thing you know you
getting hit by a car
me hitting another person too hard and
scrambling my brain yeah I was hoping
that meat was like when there's like a
huge person and they call him tiny as
his nickname but it sounds like this one
was right on the nose yeah yeah yeah his
name was Demetrius and so me was just
short for that but it was also very
fitting yeah but yeah so uh you know
that that's what that's what initially
kind of like put me down down the road
I'm currently on so yeah that's that's
that's probably the defining moment in
my life up to this point yeah so you got
your concussion and after the concussion
you got into powerlifting which is smart
that's a good plan I also as you know
had concussion issues when I was
arrested and played football as a high
school athlete and for some reason I
don't think my thinking was very
clear at the time but when I first like
was really sidelined with concussions
you know I they kind of let me come back
to finish my wrestling career but it was
kind of if he like I think if it
happened today they would not have
allowed me to but after after I finished
my career kind of barely coming back
from a concussion I was like okay what
do I do now and what I wanted to do was
get like every high school wrestler I
wanted to get into mixed martial arts
and the thing about mixed martial arts
is the head traumas kind of baked into
the cake yeah even if you're good at it
you're getting some head trauma you know
eventually and for some reason I didn't
really think that was an important
factor I was like I'm sure I'll be slick
you know I won't catch one right on the
chin I'll just do this forever and never
get hit and and that was a bad plan so I
had a coach that was like one of my
wrestling coaches who was also getting
into mixed martial arts obviously he had
been into it for like a year or two
mm-hmm but he had all the sparring gear
and he was like oh you're you want to
try this out let's give it a shot and we
were you know we were just kind of
messing around doing some boxing stuff
and you know he was a much larger person
than me and more experienced and we
tried to kind of it's kind of like with
wrestling we would do like jujitsu stuff
every now and then and just like if
you're gonna you know feel anything that
doesn't feel right just tap out we'll be
good you know we could control it and
man one time he threw a punch that just
couldn't be controlled and oh god he
caught me just square on the jaw and it
was literal literally a single instant
and in which you know all my neurons
kind of aligned and they said I don't
think we should be doing this mm-hmm and
that was actually the at the beginning
and the end of my mixed martial arts
career so if you have concussion issues
that disrupt your wrestling career my
advice would be not to transition to
mixed martial arts because you're
probably gonna get punched and/or kicked
or kneed in the face
yeah just stick with Blaine and traffic
exactly so what I did after that
actually that's when I started lifting
just to get as huge as possible I didn't
know I would end up doing bodybuilding
from it
but that's when I was like okay no more
wrestling no more getting punched in the
face I'm just gonna lift heavy stuff as
much as I can eat an obscene amount of
protein because I didn't know anything
about research at that time and and do
my best with that so so that was when I
knew you you were smart to go
powerlifting right out of the gate mixed
martial arts was not for me well I mean
yeah so I have had one more like head
trauma slash sport related scare since
then so after so after I got knocked out
of real sports at a very competitive
level I couldn't I couldn't stay away so
you know I went from playing like high
school basketball to like whatever I'll
still play rec league basketball and and
I kept playing rec league baseball as
well and one time so I was playing third
base and this kid squared around to bunt
and so I come charging down the line to
cover the bunt and at the last second he
pulls the bat back swings line drive
I'm like how long is the base path 90
feet would be 90 feet yeah yeah so I I
was I don't know maybe 35 feet away at
that point like I mean he showed bunt
early like I was ready for it hit a line
drive smacked me right in the face like
I still have a scar over my nose from it
like the laces on the ball opened my
nose right up yeah just just just
snapped that bone I think that like
severed it like a nasal artery so I was
just like I look like a rhinoceros like
blood was just spurting up out of my
face and if that ball would have been
three inches higher and caught me in the
forehead like that may have been that
second big concussion that I had trying
to avoid so funny story about that that
was a Sunday like afternoon into Sunday
evening baseball game and
so my family always went to church both
Sunday morning and Sunday evening
my parents had left the game maybe 10
minutes before that happened and I don't
remember if anyone in the family had
cell phones yet or like maybe just their
phones were turned off but I had no way
to get in touch with them and I was
losing enough blood that someone called
an ambulance because there was quite a
large pool of blood yes on the baseball
field and I realized this is supposed to
be like fun light-hearted fireside chat
content very good I promise that I'm
going to get to something kind of
amusing yet possibly in a morbid way by
the end of it so I'm like on there like
I'm on the field on my hands and knees
just like just gushing blood from my
face the ambulance shows up and they
basically said like hey they took my
blood pressure it was like super low so
they're like you've lost a lot of blood
you should probably come to the hospital
and like my dad when I was really young
had super super good medical insurance
and in hindsight like knowing what I
know now about the health insurance
marketplace in the u.s. at that time he
still had very good health insurance it
just wasn't like as crazy good as as it
had been previously like my parents
complained about their health insurance
and so I was just like oh [ __ ] I don't
know how much it's gonna cost my family
if I go to the hospital yeah and so I
said like nah like I'm not good I'm not
getting in that [ __ ] ambulance like
you're not gonna bankrupt my family and
so I I shooed them away the field was
completely unusable at this point like
they had to call the rest of the game
because oh my god yeah just to just to
contextualize it and so I at the end of
the story I did end up eventually going
to the hospital and my blood pressure
was like man I don't I don't want to lie
to you but it was somewhere in the
neighborhood of like 90 over 52 and so
they
I forget the exact number that they put
on it but like they estimated that I've
lost approximately a [ __ ] ton of blood
so the field wasn't usable at this point
the game was called and so like one of
my buddies on my team
like I asked his parents like hey my
parents are a church like that's
probably where I should go would you
mind dropping me at church and so they
said they'd look me up and down and they
were like we'll need to put out a towel
on like on the car seat for you right
but sure we can drive you to church and
so I'm I'm covered in blood just
head-to-toe at this point like the whole
front of my shirt caked in blood like
blood running down my baseball pants
there's a lot of blood in this situation
and so my parents were in church and I
got dropped off I'm like super light
headed by this point but I'm thinking
clearly enough to know that I shouldn't
walk into the front of the auditorium
you know because that might disrupt
people so I decided like ow I'll walk in
through the back of the auditorium and
like you know get my parents and we can
decide what to do from here and so I
walk in the back of the auditorium and
our preacher Claude he's this he's just
that he's just the chillest old dude
ever like nothing nothing would rile him
up completely unflappable and I walk in
the back of the auditorium I'm trying to
make as little noise as possible because
like I don't want to draw attention to
myself but I look like you know someone
from a war movie ray and Claude just
clawed just freezes mouth drops open
like from a cartoon like just mouths a
gape and he was like young man are you
okay yeah and then I'm trying not to
draw attention to myself but every
goddamn person in the auditorium turns
around and like stares at me and I'm
like well [ __ ] I feel incredibly out of
place now my plan completely backfired
thanks Claude and so like I get my
parents and I was like
can we go to the hospital okay like yes
we can go to the hospital so anyway yeah
went to the hospital they set my nose
they said it kind of crooked I broke it
again a few years later and like said it
straighter myself which was good put a
ton of blood in me and then I felt fine
had a killer headache for like a week
and a half yeah that's that story but
the important thing is it wasn't the the
it wasn't a catastrophic final
concussion to end all concussions for
you
correct he lived to fight another day I
did and I would say your brain still
functions approximately decently really
as well as one could hope it to at this
point yeah for sure alright so there you
go a little bit of injury a little bit
of concussion a little bit of getting
hit by cars those are some defining
moments in our lives
now Greg you on the show have built up a
reputation as being a bit of a culinary
expert you know I get to enjoy your
cooking firsthand you've made a lot of
very passable dishes in weeks past so
we've gotten a lot of random food
questions and I was thinking the easiest
way to do this is I just kind of run
them by you
I feel comfortable deferring to you on
this you know a lot more about food than
I know I think it should be a discussion
because now so just so you guys are
aware of how this is gonna go we're not
really talking about the science or
application of cooking and food in this
segment we're more talking about the
philosophy of food yeah I think that's
fair to say so so let's dive in and
we'll have a we'll have discussion let's
see if we can reach some common ground
on some of these topics all right and
just a warning some of these are very
controversial so I know we're gonna get
a lot of hate mail but we're gonna dive
in number one is a hot dog a sandwich a
taco or neither so in my opinion I would
say a hotdog is a taco okay what do you
think so I thought about this and I
actually really kind of blew my mind I
started to think about what are some of
the defining characteristics of a hotdog
itself before I
put it into the sandwich or the taco
category and so I would answer this
question with another question is a sub
a submarine sandwich is that a hot dog
if you think of the shape of the sub
bread you might be looking at a hot dog
there well so I think the first question
you need to ask yourself is what what is
the defining characteristic of a hot dog
is it the frankfurter sausage itself
because then the question becomes well
when is it no longer a frankfurter
sausage and thus not a hot dog so let's
imagine the thought experiment so you
have just a standard B Frank on on one
side and then you have a kielbasa on the
other side okay and there is clearly a
continuum between the two so they use
different meats they have different fat
contents different nitrate contents
different like spices and seasoning used
but one could slowly tweak the formula
and make a hot dog more kielbasa like
until it was you know definitely no
longer no longer a frankfurter right but
weird where can you draw that line and
can you draw that line I would argue
maybe no so then you open yourself up to
a world where virtually any sausage on
that shaped bun is then a hotdog and
then if you've removed the casing is it
now a fundamentally different thing yeah
I mean what about a hot dog without a
bun right yeah or you know so let's just
say you have a hot dog with relatively
of very large circumference for a hot
dog okay okay okay okay and then you cut
it into slices and you put that on a hot
dog oh okay
that isn't that different from a sub no
that is a sub yeah yeah so I guess it
comes down to three different
philosophical approaches to what hot dog
is you could say that the hot dog is the
meat product itself which the bun has no
bearing over that you could say that it
is the the meat and bun concept which
then
you up to the sub theory which is a
pretty controversial theory I think it's
compelling it's compelling though there
is it's an evidence-based theory with
some logic behind it and then another
approach is that a hot dog is basically
just a lifestyle or a mindset like the
hot dog is more of a conceptual entity
than it is a specific food item does
that make sense yeah I can see that so I
don't really know where I I'm of the
opinion that a a hot dog is a sandwich
but in reality I would actually say that
sandwich is really a hot dog you know I
would actually kind of invert the the
the scenario no I I think I think that
is a very compelling perspective yeah so
let's move on to the next one okay a
very related concept yeah stayin in the
hot dog family is a corn dog a popsicle
I would have to say yes I would think
that the fact that it is suspended on a
stick puts it in the popsicle family
because I don't see any reason that you
would have to necessarily define a
popsicle as a cold treat and I would
also apply do you remember when they
came out with those frozen food items
like at the grocery store where it was
like it was like a breakfast sausage
link on a stick wrapped in a pancake oh
yeah yeah yeah I'm also considering that
to be a popsicle as well and that one
even comes frozen so that that's right
on the mark well most corndogs do too
yeah that's true yeah yeah so what do
you think you know it's tough to say
because then so part of the word is
sickle which sounds like icicle or it
could be indicative of like hammer and
sickle I don't know that much about the
diet and Soviet Russia it could have
been very corndog heavy so I think you
know maybe we need to consider the
etymology of the term and neither of us
are corn dog
etymology expert so so we'll leave that
up to to you dear listener this thought
just came to me I could have sworn I've
told you this before
one time I was at a university event and
someone was presenting their their
dissertation topic and they were I
believe they were in the Department of
History and their dissertation was on
specifically the history of corn in
Soviet Russia between 1945 and 1954 it
was a specific 10-year period in which
they evaluated the cultural significance
of corn in the Soviet Union so that
actually might lend some evidence to
your theory that it could be a different
type of sickle altogether it could be
yeah so yeah so if we grant that a corn
dog might be a popsicle and that the
defining characteristic is just that
it's skewered on a stick then the
question becomes you know if you remove
it from the stick is it no longer a
popsicle if it was cooked on the stick
hmm yeah it's not a popsicle anymore all
right fair enough yeah definitely not so
strong verdict corn dog absolutely a
popsicle oh wait one second though oh no
what about a kebab seat so that that's
where I was going with this oh so if if
one would grant that if you've removed
the corn dog from the stick that it was
still a popsicle then one could say well
what about you know like teriyaki
chicken on a stick that you might get
from Chinese carryout mm-hmm if you
remove it then maybe that's still a
popsicle and then maybe chickens
themselves are popsicles no it's got to
be on the stick it's got to be on the
stick
okay that makes sense all right now the
couple other very controversial ones
that we want to get through here we want
to make sure people get their answers
this one is really good is a cereal soup
I would say so so you know the first
thing that may come to mind is like oh
but but it's cold like soup is generally
served warm I don't think anyone would
contend that gazpacho is not a soup very
famous cold soup so if gazpacho can be a
soup
then you know one might say well you
know you're dealing with with milk
rather than some standard soup broth
well they're there a milk and cream
based soup so we can dismiss that out of
hand
and then you know one might say the
cereal pieces that's a non-standard soup
thing but a lot of them are grain and
barley based like you can absolutely
make like a delicious barley soup the
fact that it's been processed and you
know now takes the shape of an O and is
marketed by a B it's it's no longer the
same thing I would say it still is the
same thing so yeah absolutely cereals
just a cold soup yeah this one was
cereal and soup is one of the ones where
like I'm actually struggling to think of
a counterpoint like I think that's a
very open and shut case cereal has to be
a soup because otherwise what is it yeah
it's a soup okay now we've got two that
that I'm gonna save one for the end for
obvious reasons well with this one I
want to introduce this one okay so go
ahead this isn't a question you're the
host so go ahead this is a declarative
statement okay a lasagna is a spaghetti
flavored cake from my limited knowledge
of what cake is that sounds correct to
me okay it's a layered cake yeah yeah
but but it is absolutely a cake yeah and
one might say well the noodles in a
lasagna like that's that's different
from like the standard cake cake you
know okay but oh dang it what are they
called the the little like round crepes
crepes so I've gotten into making crepes
recently the texture of like a crepe and
a well like more than al dente lasagna
noodle really not all that different and
there's there's a hot thing in kind of
like the like not Etsy what's the what's
the social media Pinterest interesting
yeah in like the Pinterest world these
days I have a Pinterest t-shirt that's
part of my style repertoire hell yeah
yeah I was given to me nice
so like crepe cakes which is essentially
you make a crepe you put a thin layer of
frosting you make another crepe then
layer frosting and just stack them up
until you have what people call a cake
that's like 50 crepe stacked up with
like thin layers of frosting in between
them Wow and so like if crepes can be
used to make a cake I don't necessarily
know that a lasagna noodle is all that
different and you have a slightly
different like layer to filling ratio
but yeah I think I think a lasagna
spaghetti flavored cake are there any
other cakes that traditionally feature
cottage cheese in them aside from
lasagna you can use cottage cheese to
make a cheese cake nice so yeah then
it's yeah that works yeah yeah so most
most Americans have probably either
mostly had or exclusively had New York
style cheesecake switch are either only
cream cheese or maybe cream cheese and
ricotta hmm but really any creamy dairy
product can can be used to make a
cheesecake so I know in some other
countries they use a product called
quark which is like somewhere I think
between cottage cheese and ricotta I
know that people make like a macro
friendly dessert which they term a
cheesecake with cottage cheese so yeah
that that's not completely off-limits
awesome now we have one additional
question here do you want to do you want
to dive in or is this another one that
you consider a definitive statement no I
would say this is a question okay so the
question here is a pop tart a ravioli I
would say probably so there there is a
difference in the you know the the the
doughy we D product surrounding the
filling but I don't necessarily know
that a ravioli has to be made with
traditional pasta dough mm-hmm
I don't know you know I don't know who
the god of ravioli is who would make
such a designation so I'm not
necessarily saying that a pop-tart is a
ravioli but I I do think one could make
that case I think it's a question worth
considering I'm very interested that you
have such such an open mind with these
categorizations because when I put
cottage cheese into lasagna you throw a
fit and all of a sudden you're saying
that pop-tart is a ravioli so where does
this where do you draw these arbitrary
distinctions I wasn't upset about the
fact that you put cottage cheese in the
lasagna like you waged a very public war
on my lasagna no no so I did the cottage
cheese like a traditional lasagna is
made with a bechamel like that's the
creamy component however there are
versions of lasagna that are made with
with cottage cheese that's the type of
lasagna that I ate growing up like it
had cottage cheese in it it is it is a
non-traditional ingredient but but it's
been used long enough especially in
American cooking that you know I'm not
gonna bulk at that it doesn't do as good
of a job at what it's supposed to do as
a nice bechamel does but it does serve
the same purpose okay my problem was the
lack of noodles oh yeah I forgot about
that that was the thing that really
drove you nuts
yeah yeah yeah you just don't eat them I
mean that that that's really all you
have to say about it so I do think a
defining characteristic of lasagna is
the fact that it has flat noodles in it
okay well we agree to disagree and I'm
comfortable with that as long as you are
fair enough all right
well we're about a hour in so do you
want to you know let people know to
review us and where they can find us and
all that stuff when we're coming back
yeah so if you like the podcast you can
review us on iTunes or whatever you know
whatever platform you listen to the
podcast on if you're listening on
YouTube don't forget to Like comment
subscribe still feel like a complete
piece of [ __ ] every time I say that if
you don't like the podcast don't leave a
[ __ ] review
we yeah we've gotten plenty of that
feedback we don't need any more of it
yeah we look we know what is wrong with
the show and at this point it should be
obvious we're never gonna change
anything so your negative feedback not
only is it not welcome it's not gonna
it's not gonna do anything you're just
wasting your own time so good vibes only
good vibes only in the review section if
you want to ask a question or suggest a
topic for us to talk about either in a
regular episode or on a fireside chat
you can do so at tiny dot CC slash SBS
QA and that's about it
hope you guys are having fun staying
safe and we'll talk to you again soon
thanks for listening to the stronger by
science podcast now Greg and I are not
experts in medicine or health or really
anything else for that matter so before
you make any changes to your diet and
exercise habits make sure you check with
a doctor or another health care
professional if you enjoyed this podcast
and you'd like to support it
visit stronger by science com2 check out
the products and services that we offer
thanks for listening and we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you